[Music]
we
all have this
secret desire
wish fantasy down inside of us that a
rich uncle
that we didn't know existed is going to
show up and save the day
we all think the calvary is coming
and and um and and i i know i sound like
an old grouch or something but the
calvary's not coming you are the calvary
you are the secret sauce you are the
answer to
your equation the white house is not
going to fix your life
you don't have a mystery rich uncle and
it's
doubtful that you have an oil field that
your great grandfather left you
that no one ever told anybody about in
the family
it's it's a fantasy thing that we all
have down inside of us that we want to
be true
that suddenly that suddenly it's going
to be easy
suddenly all of our problems are going
to be solved and we're going to click
our ruby slippers together
three times there's no place like home
there's no place like home there's no
place like home we all
have that it's part of the human nature
because we have in our spiritual dna
a memory of heaven and
and and we we're reaching for that and
we have this
thing that that's going to occur somehow
this is utopia is around the corner
it's gonna get easy there's no struggle
there are no more tears
the rich uncle is gonna die and leave us
a millionaire or there's an oil field in
the family
and so the problem you can get into
because we all have that and um
the problem is it never happens
in reality you don't have a mystery rich
uncle
you really don't i mean it doesn't
happen the the times that that happens
if you're and i want people to spend
your money
and your energy and your time on things
that do happen which is you
getting better you winning
not you there's no easy button that's a
commercial
there's not a real easy yes i totally
agree
i totally and so you because i every
time
this is how people get scammed and it
very well could be with our last caller
that the only money that is made in this
entire transaction
is a lawyer gets paid 3 500 bucks
and she's in baby step two yeah trying
to work her way out of debt
but there's this thing over in the midst
that if i could pull the curtains back
and i could get all the way it's going
to be a it's gonna get it's
not it's just i i'm sorry i don't think
so
i think if there was a multi-million
dollar thing happening over there
someone in the family would have already
been cashing in you know i mean
how screwed up and inbred does your
family have to be to walk away from a 10
million dollar
situation your cousins uncles aunts and
everybody there would have been
everybody been talking about it
it wouldn't have been a mystery
whispered as they on the death bed of
the last three people that died or
something
it would be like i mean think about it
folks if your family had their 10 or 15
million dollars laying around somewhere
everybody would be fighting over it
talking about it arguing about it
looking at it going where's those dadgum
royalty checks going
it's if it's ten dollars and it's
swampland nobody gives a crap
and and they don't pay the taxes on but
it may it may take you sixty thousand
dollars to get the back taxes paid on it
you know and so this is this is that is
wisdom
of the ages it's just it it's um
i am a young youthful hopeful person
well and you're a conspiracy theorist
you love a good conspiracy
and you love a good mystery you love a
good your mama loves a good moment
like why not and this is like a mystery
it could be it could be and it's okay to
investigate it
chances are but don't place your hope on
the white house the white house is not
going to fix you
joe biden or donald trump or whoever
ends up up there isn't going to fix your
life
i'm old i've seen a bunch of every brand
and
and every one of them comes in promising
crap
and so far none of them have made my
life good
they just take stuff from me at the
point of a gun
you know called the irs you know they
don't they don't
give me you know and so i'm not watching
the democratic
zoom or the republican zoom
convention going oh oh finally finally
now it's going to be okay
do you notice we're not going to talk
about it we're going to drop it in a
second i know
but it's just it is funny though every
election though they say this is the
most important election
every election this is the most
important election
this is the most important and what
happens up there is important because
those people can screw up christmas
oh my god the island of misfit toys on
parade
and and so you know but but don't place
your hope
on the wrong stuff let me just tell you
place your hope
on those two hands that are in front of
you those skills that god
gave you the energy that he gave you the
creativity that he gave you the power to
work and earn
money that he gave you place your hope
on a system that you
work a system that causes you to get out
of debt and build
wealth and change your and you change
your family tree
now there's a place you can place your
hope you know
but but the the the answer to my
business problems are not
some dead gum consultant that comes in
from the outside and has all the answers
they don't if they if they had all the
answers they wouldn't be a consultant
they would be running a business
i mean i don't mind listening to a
consultant and we do consulting with
people
but we're teaching them and helping them
do it for themselves
there's no magic pill there's no pill
there's not a one pill i'm going to take
one thing's going to happen it's all
going to be okay all of a sudden it's
okay
it's not going to be okay that's you
know it's the same crap with the vaccine
on coven
cove it'll all be okay when there's a
vaccine no well
no i won't it'll still be covered and
people are still gonna be
nut burgers about it one way or the
other they're still going to be going
crazy
out there right same with the lottery
same with lottery you're looking for a
magic i
don't have that yet i'm looking for
looking for an easy button yep i want an
easy button i want someone else to make
this easy for me
i want yolanda to call back in six
months and tell me
that i was wrong i got 10 million
off of some swamp land in louisiana that
had gas
wells on it remember me yolanda remember
me
i've i believed in you
[Laughter]
i don't i hey i believe in you women no
no i believe in yolanda that's my point
i just don't believe in her swamp land
yeah that's right that's that's it
i'm just saying i mean i know i'm just
playing yep it's possible
yes so investigate it but but no
yes putting your hope in your energy and
everything yes place your dreams
right now i hear that your hopes and and
lean over on it to where when it
crumbles you fall over
don't don't place your hope on the wrong
things it'll it'll steal
your hope and and you you'll be cr you
know your emotion it takes you a decade
to emotionally and financially recover
this is how people gets conned that
they're trying to get an easy button
i wrote a ridiculous book when i was
16 or years old my dad read it handed it
to me called con man or saint
this guy was a con man he was a
legitimate real con man
and he'd stolen millions of dollars from
people and he was in jail he wrote the
book from jail
but the only i don't remember anything
about the book except the vague sense of
the story
and this phrase he said it's almost
impossible to con someone who isn't
greedy
oh wow that's good you're trying to get
something for nothing
and the con man presents you something
for nothing and so you
bite and if you don't
if you're not greedy you don't bite
and so that i thought man that's an
indictment of his victims
he obviously was in jail he was
obviously a jerk right
sure his book was called con man or
saint because he wasn't sure but we were
all sure if we read the book it was a
con man
but the uh he wasn't a saint but the
point his point is true
and i find myself when i get desperate
then i'm in a sense that's a type of
greed
and i get i can get over in this thing
and
all of a sudden i'm doing stupid butt
stuff that i don't need to be doing
all in the name of desperation or easy
money easy money
easy money hit the easy button folks
you're your secret sauce you're the
answer to the equation you can do this
stuff